One thing that has fascinated me for literally my entire life, is stars, and
how far away from us they are. Did you know that when we look at a star, like
the sun for example, we're looking at something from the past because of the
time it takes the light to reach us. That's pretty weird and pretty awesome, I
think. So let's work out how long it takes the light to reach us from the sun.
As you saw before, the distance from the earth to the sun is approximately 1.5
times 10 to the 11th meters. Light travels at a speed of 3 times 10 to the 8th
meters per second. As we can see from the units of speed here, meters per
second, speed is equal to some distance, divided by the time it takes to go
that distance. Now thinking about this equation, what do we need to do to
calculate time? Do we need to multiply speed by distance, divide distance by
speed or divide speed by distance?